[Music]
around 40 soldiers came home just in
time for Thanksgiving in Colorado they
were greeted with hugs yesterday after
being deployed in Afghanistan for nine
months tens of thousands of troops will
spend Thanksgiving away from their
families to protect our country but
their sacrifice will not be forgotten
chip Reid visited a new museum that
ensures all those who served will be
remembered need met with former Joint
Chiefs chairman General Colin Powell who
explained the significance of the new
exhibits good morning all across the
country there are memorials to those who
fought in wars from the American
Revolution to Iraq and Afghanistan but
there's never been a National Museum for
all veterans who've served in war and in
peace
but a recently opened museum in Columbus
Ohio has changed that a monument that
says thank you the new National Veterans
Memorial and Museum pays homage to the
more than 40 million men and women who
have served in the United States
military there are displays you might
expect Civil War era hats first aid kits
dating back 200 years and boots from a
fallen soldier in Iraq and then watch
the transition of helmets over the years
but : POW the honorary chair of the
museum's Board of Directors says it's
about so much more I wasn't planning to
get on another museum board but once I
came out here when it was under
construction and I had to be a part of
it it is unique in that it focuses on
the individual soldier sailor Airman
marine it's not about the battle it's
not about the generals it's about the
folks who actually get the job done
there are no tanks in here don't need
any there no planes no planes it is a
quiet place where the focus is totally
on the individual Gi Gi is like Tom Tran
who was shot in the head four days into
his first combat mission in Iraq in the
back of the head back that you were
still conscious
I still conscious bandaged my own head
cracked a couple jokes trying to keep
myself awake
and we finished the mission I never even
thought about the military walls growing
up me Tran tells his story of service in
video exhibits throughout the museum a
lot of veterans come back and they feel
like they don't have anybody to share
their story with and this is proof that
they can share that story there are
interactive exhibits like this one which
shows the number and location of US
troops throughout the decades colonel
and of course stories of enlisting of
sacrifice of coming home from the famous
to the anonymous I never would have
thought anybody would be interested in
my story but why why should me you know
I gave 17 years to this country and I
think anybody who's worn that uniform
deserves to hear their story towed the
museum doesn't shy away from some of the
military's thorny ER issues by the time
I graduated college I was a single
mother when jaspen Boothe was discharged
after a cancer diagnosis she found there
were no services for her or her son I
took an old 17 years ago to never leave
a fallen comrade and once I saw that
that was a void that became my next
mission and what did you do exactly so I
started in a nonprofit organization
called finest food Inc and our mission
to survive homeless women veterans and
their children with safe and suitable
housing this is when you first went to
Vietnam 23 years young 23 years yeah how
long before you went became a prisoner
of war was that well that was September
of 1967 and my airplane went down in
January 68 Tom mo was a P o w4 more than
five years his daughter was an infant
when he left and six when he returned
and we had two more kids after I came
home our boys and they've each have
three kids you know I cherished my whole
family with my boys and my grandkids
would have never been born had I not
come home do you think this museum will
appeal to civilians and military and
veterans alike I hope so because we will
only have about 1% of the American
population involved in military
operations and so it is important that
the other 99% know of their sacrifice
and why they're sacrificing and what
that sacrifice is like
of the more than 40 million Americans
who have served in the military about
half are alive today
bianna it's an important reminder that
yesterday we lost the oldest living
Pearl Harbor survivor Rey Chavez 106
years old you think of these ordinary
Americans making such extraordinary
decisions and bravery fighting for this
country duty honor country grace under
pressure and what you heard that
veterans say there finish the mission
yeah merica telling ya the ordinary
stuff